subió a un autobús en Delhi con su amigo.
Había 6 hombres jóvenes en el autobús
que una podría encontrar a diario en India,
y el escalofriante relato de lo que siguió
se mostró una y otra vez
en los medios indios e internacionales.
Esta joven fue violada reiteradamente,
penetrada por la fuerza con una varilla,
golpeada, mordida, hasta morir.
Su amigo, amordazado, atacado
y golpeado, quedó inconsciente.
Ella murió el 29 de diciembre.
Y mientras muchos de los presentes
nos disponíamos a recibir el año nuevo,
India se sumía en la oscuridad.
Por primera vez en nuestra historia,
hombres y mujeres de India
despertamos a la horrible verdad
del estado de las mujeres en el país.
Como muchas otras jóvenes,
yo estaba aterrada.
No podía creer que algo así
ocurriese en una capital nacional.
Me enojé y estaba frustrada,
pero sobre todo, me sentí completamente indefensa.
Pero realmente, qué hacer, ¿no?
Algunos escriben blogs, otros lo ignoran,
algunos protestan.
Yo hice todo eso. Era lo que todos hacían
hace 2 años.
Los medios estaban repletos de historias
de los actos horribles
de los que los hombres indios eran capaces.
Se los comparó con animales,
bestias sexuales reprimidas.
Tan ajeno e impensable era este acontecimiento
para la mentalidad india
que la respuesta de los medios indios,
el público y los políticos mostraron
que nadie sabía qué hacer.
Nadie asumía la responsabilidad.
Estos son algunos comentarios insensibles
que aparecieron en los medios, de gente importante
["La violación de jovencitas es entendible pero la de los niños, inimaginable"]
["Las chicas deberían llamar hermanos a los violadores"]
El primero pertenece a un parlamentario,
el segundo a un líder espiritual,
y el tercero ["Las víctimas de violación de Delhi son las culpables"]
a un abogado de los acusados mientras la joven fallecía.
Como mujer, ver esto a diario,
me cansó.
Como escritora y activista de cuestiones de género,
he escrito mucho sobre la mujer,
pero esta vez me di cuenta de que era distinto,
porque una parte de mí se dio cuenta
de que era parte de esa joven también,
y decidí que quería cambiar esto.
Así que hice algo espontáneo, apresurado.
Me conecté a una plataforma de periodismo ciudadano
llamada iReport,
y grabé un video hablando
de la situación en Bangalore.
Conté cómo me sentía,
conté las realidades sobre el terreno,
y hablé de las frustraciones de vivir en India.
En pocas horas, el blog se compartió ampliamente
y llegaron comentarios y pensamientos
de todo el mundo.
En ese momento, se me ocurrieron algunas cosas.
Una, la tecnología siempre estaba disponible
para jóvenes como yo.
Dos, que al igual que yo, raramente
las jóvenes como yo expresan sus opiniones.
Tres, me di cuenta por primera vez
de que mi voz importa.
Por eso en los meses siguientes,
cubrí una serie de eventos en Bangalore
que no eran noticia en los medios principales
En Cubbon Park, un gran parque de Bangalore,
me reuní con otras 100 personas
cuando un grupo de jóvenes se pusieron
faldas para demostrar que la ropa
no invita a la violación.
Cuando informé estos eventos,
sentí que tenía un canal
para liberar las emociones que tenía dentro.
Fui a la marcha de la alcaldía
en la que los estudiantes tenían pancartas que decían:
"Mátenlos, cuélguenlos".
"No le harían esto a sus madres o hermanas".
Fui a una vigilia con velas
donde los ciudadanos se reunieron
a hablar abiertamente sobre la violencia sexual,
y recuerdo muchos blogs
en respuesta a lo preocupante de la situación.
["Mis hermanas y primas viven en ciudades y en el extranjero,
pero ni hablaron ni se quejaron de las dificultades que dices"]
Esas reacciones me confundieron.
Así como llegaban comentarios de apoyo de todo el mundo,
también hubo comentarios maliciosos.
Algunos me llamaron hipócrita.
Decían que yo hacía apología de la víctima, de la violación.
Algunos incluso me dijeron que tenía motivación política.
Este comentario describe
lo que discutimos hoy.
Pero no tardé en advertir que esto no era todo.
Empoderada como me sentía
con la nueva libertad que este
canal de periodismo ciudadano me daba,
me encontré en una situación desconocida.
En agosto pasado, entré a Facebook,
estaba mirando las novedades,
y advertí que había un enlace
compartido por mis amigos.
Hice clic en el enlace y me llevó
a un informe subido por una chica de EE. UU.
llamada Michaela Cross.
El informe se titulaba:
"India: La historia que nunca quisieras escuchar".
En ese informe contaba de primera mano
el acoso sexual en India.
Escribió: "No hay manera de prepararse para los ojos,
los ojos que cada día clavan la mirada
con tanto descaro sobre mi cuerpo,
sin cambio de expresión,
les devuelva o no la mirada.
Al caminar a la frutería o la modista
recibo miradas tan penetrantes
que podrían cortarme en trozos, rodaja por rodaja".
Llamaba a India, el paraíso del viajero y el infierno de la mujer.
Dijo que fue objeto de miradas, toques,
y masturbaciones.
Más tarde esa noche, el informe se hizo viral.
Estaba en las noticias de todo el mundo.
Todo el mundo lo discutía.
Tuvo más de un millón de vistas,
mil comentarios y referencias,
y yo misma presencié
algo muy similar.
Los medios cayeron en este ciclo vicioso
de opinión y arrebatos,
sin resultados.
Esa noche, viendo cómo
debería responder,
estaba llena de dudas.
Verán, como escritora, encaraba este tema
como observadora,
como india, sentía vergüenza e incredulidad,
y como activista, lo veía como defensora de derechos,
pero como periodista ciudadana,
me sentí muy vulnerable.
Digo, aquí estaba ella, una mujer joven
que usaba un canal para hablar
de su experiencia como hacía yo,
y aún así yo estaba inquieta.
Nunca nadie te dice
que el verdadero empoderamiento viene de darse uno
el permiso para pensar y actuar.
A menudo, el empoderamiento suena
a ideal, a resultado maravilloso.
A menudo, al hablar de empoderamiento,
hablamos de darle a las personas acceso a materiales,
acceso a herramientas.
Pero, el empoderamiento es una emoción.
Es un sentimiento.
El primer paso para el empoderamiento
es darse uno mismo la autoridad,
la clave de la voluntad independiente,
y para las mujeres de todas partes,
sin importar quiénes seamos o de dónde venimos,
ese es el paso más difícil.
Le tememos al sonido de nuestra propia voz,
porque significa admisión, pero es ella la que nos da
el poder de cambiar el entorno.
En esta situación en la cual enfrentaba
tantas realidades diferentes,
no sabía cómo juzgar
porque yo no sabía qué significaría para mí.
Temía juzgar porque no sabía qué pasaría
si no apoyaba la misma mirada de esta chica.
No sabía qué significaría para mí
desafiar la verdad del otro.
Pero, sin embargo, era simple.
Tuve que tomar una decisión:
¿Debería hablar o permanecer en silencio?
Después de mucho pensarlo,
grabé un video en respuesta,
y le dije a Michaela, bueno,
que India tiene varios aspectos,
y también traté de explicarle
que las cosas estarían bien
y le expresé mi pesar por lo que había enfrentado.
Unos días después, me invitaron a hablar
al aire con ella,
y por primera vez, me acerqué a esta chica
que no conocía, que estaba tan lejos,
pero que sentía tan cercana.
Desde que salió a la luz este informe,
más cantidad de jóvenes que nunca
discutían sobre acoso sexual en el campus,
y la universidad a la que pertenecía Michaela
le dio la asistencia que necesitaba.
La universidad tomó incluso las medidas
para entrenar a sus estudiantes
en las habilidades que necesitaban
para enfrentar desafíos como el acoso,
y, por primera vez, sentí que no estaba sola.
Si algo aprendí
como periodista ciudadana activa
en los años pasados,
es nuestra grave falta como sociedad para buscar activamente
vías de expresión para nuestras voces.
No nos damos cuenta de que al reclamar,
no lo hacemos como individuos,
sino como comunidad, en nombre
de nuestros amigos y pares.
Muchos decimos que se le niegan los derechos a la mujer,
pero a menudo la verdad es que
las propias mujeres nos negamos estos derechos.
En una encuesta reciente en India,
el 95 % de las mujeres que trabajan en TI,
aviación, hotelería y centros de llamadas,
dijeron no sentirse a salvo de regreso a casa solas
luego de trabajar hasta altas horas o por la tarde.
En Bangalore, de donde vengo,
este número es el 85 %.
En zonas rurales de India,
a juzgar por las recientes
violaciones en grupo en Badaun y ataques con ácido en Odisha
y Aligarh,
tenemos que actuar realmente pronto.
No me malinterpreten,
los desafíos que enfrentarán las mujeres
al contar sus historias son reales,
pero tenemos que empezar a buscar
y tratar de identificar los medios
para participar en nuestro sistema
y no solo buscar los medios a ciegas.
Hoy, más mujeres que nunca
reclaman y cuestionan
al gobierno indio,
y esto es resultado de ese coraje.
Hay un aumento de 6 veces en la denuncia
de acoso de mujeres,
y el gobierno indio aprobó
la enmienda al Código Penal en 2013
para proteger a las mujeres contra el ataque sexual.
Para terminar esta charla
solo quiero decir
que sé que todos tenemos secretos,
pero hablemos en voz alta.
Venzamos la vergüenza y hablemos de ello.
Podría ser en una plataforma, en una comunidad,
con los seres queridos, donde y con quienes queramos,
pero hablemos en voz alta.
La verdad es que al final este problema
empieza por nosotros.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)